en este vídeo vamos a probar que si
tenemos un triángulo rectángulo entonces
su círculo es el punto medio de la
hipotenusa vale bueno entonces aquí
tenemos el triángulo rectángulo con
ángulo recto en ce y lo primero que
vamos a hacer es trazar la media triz
del segmento bc esa media triz debe de
pasar aquí por el punto medio de bc
déjame llamarle a ese punto medio m y
además debe de ser perpendicular a veces
entonces más o menos sería algo de este
estilo para ver si me queda bien algo
así vale entonces tenemos que aquí es un
ángulo recto que aquí es un ángulo recto
y aquí al punto en donde corta al
segmento ave vamos a llamarle el punto o
el punto o entonces el plan para ver que
el circo un centro es el punto medio de
ave es mostrar que es el punto medio de
ave y que o equidista de los tres
vértices vamos a hacer eso poco a poco
veamos que los triángulos veo m&b hace
parecen ser semejantes de hecho este es
un argumento que hemos dado varias veces
y pues seguramente va a volver
porque son semejantes porque tienen el
ángulo aquí el ángulo recto en común o
sea
mb y se ve los dos son ángulos rectos y
entonces bastaría que compartieran un
ángulo más para que fueran triángulos
semejantes pero claramente comparten el
ángulo en b es decir vm es igual a abc
es básicamente el visto el mismo ángulo
visto en dos triángulos distintos y por
lo tanto estos dos triángulos son
semejantes por el criterio ángulo ángulo
entonces aquí le voy a poner que el
triángulo
v m es semejante al triángulo
v y bueno como estos dos triángulos son
semejantes lo que podemos hacer ahora es
trabajar con las razones entre los lados
correspondientes porque la razón entre
lados correspondientes siempre debe de
ser la misma va entonces por ejemplo
podemos obtener a partir de esta
semejanza que bm
bm entre veces entre veces es este lado
entre este lado es igual a la razón de
las hipotenusa osea veo entrevea es
igual a veo veo / vea pero observa
tenemos que m es punto medio
entonces bm es igual a ms de esta forma
la razón bm entre veces es este cachito
entre dos veces este cachito vale
entonces esta razón de acá es igual a un
medio y por lo tanto veo entre vea
también es igual a un medio aquí podemos
multiplicar cruzado verdad y vamos a ver
qué nos dice eso de ahí si multiplicamos
vea para caídos para acá tenemos que que
vea vea es igual a dos veces veo o bien
otra forma de pensar en esta igualdad es
como que vea entre dos vea entre dos es
igual a b
vale entonces si dividimos vea entre dos
nos queda veo por esta razón este
cachito este cachito veo es igual a vea
medios
entre dos y entonces este cachito de acá
el cachito
pues es vea menos vea medios y también
es ve
medios muy bien entonces que nos está
diciendo esto bueno eso justo nos está
diciendo que o es el punto medio de de
ave si esta longitud esta longitud es
igual a esta longitud de acá entonces
déjame ponerlo por aquí arriba en algún
lugar con color azul le voy a poner un
punto medio punto medio medio de ave de
ave pero además ya habíamos visto en
otros vídeos que no es equidistante debe
y dice vale entonces pues vamos a poner
eso o b es igual a 12 porque o está en
la media triz entonces lo voy a poner
por acá o b uve es igual a 12 pero
entonces pues veo es punto medio de ave
también nos dice que oa es igual a v y
por supuesto si tenemos estas dos
igualdades también tenemos que ahora es
igual a 12 entonces tenemos que o es un
punto que exista de a dv y dc es decir
esta longitud de esta longitud es igual
a esta longitud de acá y también es
igual a esta longitud de acá vale
entonces esas que marque con dos rayitas
también son iguales a esta de acá por lo
tanto o equidista
equidista
lista de abc de a b c y eso simplemente
es otra forma de decir que es el circo
un centro de abc entonces o circuns
entro cirque un centro
de el triángulo a b c muy bien entonces
lo que acabamos de probar ahorita es que
si tomamos el punto medio el punto medio
del ave entonces ese punto equidistante
los tres vértices y por lo tanto ese
punto debe de ser el círculo centro
porque el círculo centro de un triángulo
es único